[Music]
hi I'm Mike at Rossi I'm here at keep
Connie EU in Copenhagen walking the
floor and I'm here with Ronnie ah snot
from aqua security hello how are you
right very busy so tell me a little bit
about aqua security so we provide full
lifecycle security solutions for
container and cloud native applications
what is full lifecycle mean right so we
think that containers change not just
how applications to our deploy but also
how they're developed so you need to
embed security early on the process so
we start by integrating through the CI
CD process then through the registry to
deployment and runtime in production
this morning we had a great announcement
we know cloud security command center
integration so that aqua security can
write findings directly to that right
and customers can see that a single pane
of glass tell me a little bit more about
that right so we you know as a security
solution we create all sorts of events
and alerts that our customers need to
understand what's happening in their
environment their security posture
compliance posture and so forth but
customers seldom want another yet
another dashboard to work with so they
were looking for something more
centralizing so by passing this
information which includes things like
vulnerability status runtime events in
containers that are misbehaving maybe or
images that were prevented from running
because of security policy we pass all
those things and in the cloud security
command center they can see all of that
in addition to other events from GCP
that theory you know get everything
happening in their one yeah we get a
demo of course sounds good
okay so we're looking at the Google
Cloud Security Command Center list of
findings in here under aquas security we
can see that there are runtime
violations and vulnerability violations
as well as images surance violations
which means that these are images that
were not approved by the system let's
take a look at a runtime violation and
there are details here that are fed by
by acqua you can see that the action
here was detect meaning this was
actually blocked that depends on policy
and if we look at more details of how it
looks on on the Aqua console we can see
information about the exact nature and
paths of this of this violation some
environment variables most importantly
we can see in the audit screen that this
was actually an action triggered by a
vulnerability known as shell shock which
in which a user tried to do a pivotal
distillation and aqua detected that in
this case thanks so much of that that
was great to see how we detected runtime
findings and then saw them directly and
CSCC yes it's pretty cool isn't it thank
you so much for your time are you having
a great time here at cube con yes it's
amazing a really amazing conference
hopefully we'll see you again in Seattle
you will and thanks to all those at home
for watching